[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the daily
miracle miss suzy boniface and former
conservative special advisor anita
wating they'll both be with us from now
until just before midnight so let's see
what's on some of those front pages for
you now
on the front page of the telegraph
thousands of onshore wind turbines may
be built under new plans to generate
more energy
and the times front page features the
story of a uk missile shooting down the
first russian helicopter
covered numbers feature on the front
page of the guardian as the cases hit an
all-time high
and the ft also leads on rising covert
cases with officers emptying as
infections increase
reminder now that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and i'm joined tonight by suzy boniface
and anita boiteng welcome to you both
let's start with the telegraph front
page um and uh
thousands of turbine um
to uh treble onshore wind power uh this
at the looking at an alternative
source of of energy which has um really
come to the fore and is is pressing
right now uh susie take us into this
story
yeah so this is going to cause a massive
split in the conservative party
boris johnson needs to find some cheap
energy quickly
and the cheapest way of doing it and
getting it soonest is wind energy and
we've already got 649 wind farms that
are approved they've got planning
permission but they're not been built
and because they're in quite rural areas
sometimes it's difficult to connect them
to the grid so it takes some effort and
his party his back benches are very very
anti the idea of wind farms being
onshore which are mostly going to be in
rural areas where there's good lots of
wind of course um so it causes him a
huge problem but he's also got i mean i
i wouldn't want to be boris johnson
today because this is a very sticky
wicket to be on
uh you can't do anything else any
quicker than this this is the quickest
way of doing it and it's the cheapest
way of doing it
if you cast your mind back to 2016 when
after we had finished ramming about
brexit well we didn't really finish in
2016 did we we were still worrying about
it but september that year theresa may
finally approved hinckley point c a new
nuclear power station now she had hund
and hoard about that decision for months
and at that point it was already eight
years delayed
okay
and when she finally approved it and
said okay you've got to go ahead with it
uh the entire british public there were
surveys showing that they really didn't
approve of new nuclear energy at all
then there was a big kerfuffle about
chinese security
and the security of the site and whether
chinese firms like huawei were allowed
to provide um services to the site and
then they had to get kicked out and it's
just been chewed up and chewed up and
chewed up if all the prime ministers
before boris johnson had actually had
decent functioning energy policies that
had produced some energy rather than
constantly kicking the can down the road
then he wouldn't be in this situation
now he is in the situation now we've got
war in ukraine we can't have russian oil
and gas anymore and we also need to try
and find a way to reduce our reliance on
oil and gas generally um
i'm glad it's not me having to make this
decision but that's why you're going to
hear a lot about wind turbines in the
next few months uh we're going to come
back to that uh but just want to bring
you some breaking news that we're
hearing by the reuters news agency and
that is that a u.s judge has upheld
gulen maxwell's sex trafficking
conviction
this is despite a juror's acknowledgment
that he had falsely stated before the
trial he had not been sexually abused
so just to reiterate that to breaking
news a judge has upheld glenn maxwell's
sex trafficking conviction and that's
despite uh that juror acknowledging that
he had falsely stated before the trial
that he had not been sexually abused if
anything further comes in on that story
we will of course uh bring it to you but
let's return to our newspaper review and
anita your thoughts in terms of um wind
power energy obviously being the
cheapest but not so
not so popular with back benches as
we've heard
well i mean the interesting thing about
wind power is that it's not just about
popularity with conservative
backbenchers actually there's a broad
challenge in this country whether it
comes to house building or on shore wind
and that people like the ideas of it but
not necessarily near their homes um and
so i think that this idea that it's just
a conservative problem or challenge i
don't think is that
and the other thing i'd say is that
fundamentally
it was new labor that had a moratorium
on on a nuclear energy which caused a
massive break in investment in energy
and nuclear energy which is going to be
absolutely essential for um energy
security and i think that the debate in
the conservative party has really moved
when it comes to energy because now
we can talk about net zero as being
absolutely intrinsic to energy security
and it being framed in that fashion and
that the prime minister and
quasi-quality and rishi sunak all
grappling with the idea of how to
efficiently bring on clean energy as a
more secure way of getting energy that
doesn't involve russian gas etc it's
really quite a marked step change and
one that i think most people that care a
lot about the environment would applaud
and i think that this
proposal when it comes forward i mean
we've been waiting a little while now
we'll bring together i think that
pragmatism around um nuclear as well as
being and making a massive push on wind
and i think it's let's not forget the
conservative environment network that
group of mps is about 140 mp strong it's
one of the biggest groups of
conservatives in westminster so i think
there's a lot of support for these kinds
of policies but what backbenchers are
accurately reflecting i think is a
degree of hesitancy about the benefits
um that the rural constituents might
feel at having these onshore wind farms
so near their home not not in my
backyard essentially a bit of nimbyism
but it's worth reminding people that
boris johnson had previously called
onshore wind turbines white satanic
mills and ludicrous wind farms that
failed to pull the skin off for rice
pudding
you laughed but that was his view
it really has come on and i think it's
become much more energy and cost
efficient first of all and actually they
are more powerful now but i do i do love
a boris johnson turn of phrase
okay that's that's a nice way to get get
round that one uh let's move on to the
guardian uh record covered numbers and
on the day that uh free tests are no
longer to be made available susie
yeah so this is really convenient um the
the good news with this is that the
the increasing cases that we're
experiencing now this huge spike for the
ba2 variant um there's two things
they're really good about it firstly if
you've had the previous ba1 omicron
variant you're very unlikely to catch
this one it's very very transmissible
the new variant but it is not going to
be
re-re-transmissible as it were you're
likely to dodge it if you've had omicron
already
and secondly is that it because it's
increasing so rapidly that means it will
also decline very rapidly it will peak
quickly and decline quickly so that's
the bit of good news that's buried at
the end of that story in the guardian
but in the meantime of course and as
there's a report in the ft as well there
are lots and lots of businesses
reporting lots of absences um there are
lots of families lots of people who are
shielding who are very very worried
again about catching it and of course um
all the restrictions and so on have been
lifted and there's going to be people
who are very concerned and working as
well in the nhs so we're going to have
to deal with this big peak as it comes
in hopefully it ends quickly and we can
all get through it but they've got to
get through that yet
anita it's very clear that we're not
entirely out of the pandemic but the
infrastructure to to track it um is
being uh
gotten rid of
well i mean i would say the the the
consensus view appears to be that we're
not quite in a pandemic we are moving to
that endemic phase where we will get
variance and there's i mean the
epidemiologists are very sure about this
that they will get i mean ba2 for
instance um
you say that we're we're coming out of
the pandemic moving to an endemic status
but but kobet has hit an all-time high
it's still it's still an issue and
people are not going to be able to
access free tests so we've got no way
after today really of tracking it unless
people
decide to pay for these tests
yes and i think that you know the
government obviously has made that view
of their decision about the fact that we
were spending i believe it's 24 billion
but someone please correct me if i'm
wrong on that on testing and there was
this view that there was a need to kind
of roll back on some of that funding and
that really you know you've seen that
the chancellor stick to his decision to
increase national insurance for instance
so that there's more resource going into
the nhs in the hope that actually this
is now a phase where the nhs can cope
with those cases and ultimately right
now we're not seeing a huge increase in
um hospital admissions even though as
you said jillian cases are actually
around five billion and five million
sorry um had covered last week so it's
relatively high what we're not seeing is
that kind of severity that requires
hospitalization which means the nhs
should still be able to cope and
obviously for the most vulnerable people
they will still be able to get free
tests
yes and the article saying that uh
hopefully hospitalizations will start
falling in the next week or so that's
according to paul hunter professor of
medicine at the university of east
anglia
let's move on to the
times
and take a look at uh ukraine at susie
uh and bring us up to data with
everything that's happening today yes so
um there's been another bit of good news
i must be in a really perky mood i keep
talking about good news today um but
basically what's happened here is that
one a british
a belfast built uh missile system called
star street it cost a hundred thousand
pounds a missile but it is believed to
have been responsible for in its first
trip out in the field in ukraine has
been responsible for bringing down uh
there's a there's footage of bringing
down a russian helicopter actually split
it in two
and it's one of those ones which can get
around anti-anti-missile measures
because it is guided to its target by
someone on the ground it's not a fire
and forget system but this is uh built
by thales in belfast it's provided by
the british government it's defending
ukraine it's shooting down aircraft it's
effectively contributing to something of
a of a no-fly zone put it that way and
it's it's a bit of
positive news although you know the
making of missiles and the
the deaths of people involved is not
something to be cheered
there's there's something positive
happening there that we are actually
doing to achieve some change on the
ground the issue is of course how many
of those we have how many of those
ukraine needs
and how long this is all going to drag
out for
um and how many more we may have to
provide over the long term because
there's no real indication at the moment
although putin's forces are pulling back
out of kiev and they seem to have been
defeated locally there's some concerns
that he's just going to regroup in
belarus resupply his troops and push
them back out again
the fact you've got to resupply your
troops in a different country is a
terrible sign for an invading force it
shows you've got no logistics and no
supply chains
and it also shows that unfortunately he
just really doesn't care about the fact
he's picking up these conscripts and
throwing them at the missiles of of the
countries that are supporting ukraine so
it does look like um he's he's bogged
down for the foreseeable
and susie
just to
expand and on that how do you think
putin is going to view the fact that a
british missile system um is thought to
have shut down a russian helicopter
well i think that all depends on whether
or not anybody's actually telling that
man the truth
and all the reports we've seen and the
intelligence that seems to have come out
of russia in the past few weeks is that
this is a man who gets up in the morning
and his generals and his little coterie
of ex-kgb agents around him lie to him
on a daily basis about how everything's
marvelous they've lied to him for 20
years about how yes mr putin we've
definitely serviced the tanks yes mr
putin we've definitely put oil in the
engine blocks and we've definitely done
this and the aircraft are marvelous and
we've got these fantastic missiles they
can do anything and then when he
actually has to go and use them he finds
out they weren't serviced the truck
tires have perished uh the conscripts
have got as we know they've got um field
bandages from the 1970s they've got food
packages and rations from the 1990s
and it would appear that you know a man
leader who is corrupt and a gangster and
is leading a corrupt regime as just
taught by
example and all the people underneath
him are also
robbing and corrupt and they just
they've been knicking stuff off the
state for the entire time that he's been
in powers consequently the military
isn't very good
and uh anita in terms of the uh
missile system being used the british
missile system being used the ukrainians
have been trained by the the the brits
to uh use this system um originally it
was thought it would take three or so
weeks to to get them up to speed but
they've managed to do it in record time
absolutely and i think this is again
testament to the willingness of the uk
to be a real partner in both kind of
sharing expertise as well as resource to
help the ukrainians in their kind of
hours and months of need
but i think this is a really interesting
question because we're kind of in a
situation where the ukrainians are
putting up such a fight that they're
able to repel the russian advance but
the question is can they then move to a
situation where they are they are
advancing and they are able to push
russia out of particular areas and i
think that's where it's going to become
very interesting jillian which is and
you know there's a difference of opinion
between for instance france and the uk
about how much um resource how much the
the european power should lead into that
army and for instance should europe be
providing tanks should nato be providing
tanks that allow the ukrainians to
retake territory and i think that's
where the debate is going to be moving
next
susie take us into the uh daily
telegraph and this uh story that that
speculates about the health of president
putin
yeah i'll just say luckily uh it seems
that vladimir putin is providing tanks
to the ukrainians so they're kind of
using that to push them back out we'll
see how that one pans out but no so on
the front of the telegraph there's a
report that um
from a russian investigative website i
think it is that he's been visited
vladimir putin's been visited by a
thyroid cancer doctor
35 times at his dakota on the black sea
um and this sort of pays into the
suggestions that he's an unwell man he's
very puffy um he seems to be quite
paranoid he's keeping everybody at arm's
length well not arm's length just a
massive tables length away from him in
the kremlin
and if you do have a problem with your
thyroid you are on steroids that makes
you puffy it makes you very irritable it
means that you have a lot of problems
for a while with your throat and
swallowing and coughing and so on which
may mean you become more paranoid about
things like covid i think you've had
that but once you've had any kind of
surgery on your thyroid you do have
regular checkups afterwards to see if
the cancer's returned so it does look
like perhaps that would
uh be a be an explanation that would
fulfill some of the things we have seen
in vladimir putin we know he disappeared
for about a month in september so that
may explain perhaps there was some
treatment of some sort that he underwent
um but we don't know what kind if that's
true there are several different kinds
of thyroid cancer many of them um are
easier to treat and may be seen in
younger people the ones often seen in
older people are usually harder to treat
and harder to survive so
if he's got one of those then you know
his time may not be
very
long okay we have something we have
the incredible detail in this piece
about how he's taken to apparently
bathing in the blood extracted from
antlers
anita we must
we must uh leave it there there has been
much speculation about putin's help for
some time we are going to take a break
do stay where you are coming up the
express reporting that prince andrew is
keen to play a key role in the queen's
platinum jubilee celebrations do stay
with us for more after the break
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me still the daily mirror
economist susie boniface and former
conservative special adviser anita
um let's take a look at the express
front page um and uh seemingly prince
andrew is uh going to take part in the
platinum jubilee celebrations and we'll
we'll have a visible role um susie
yeah turns out a man who's prepared to
pay 12 million to make something go away
and then parade in front of the cameras
when he didn't absolutely have to is not
going to go away quietly um so this is a
suggestion that despite uh apparently
lots of briefings going out to royal
reporters in the last week or two that
his appearance at his father prince
phillips memorial was going to be his
last appearance in public life prince
andrew is now keen we're here to play a
role in the platinum jubilee which is uh
coming up in june um there's also a
falklands war memorial uh event that's
going to be taking place soon so you may
want to be involved in that as well who
knows but um it's just it sort of shows
a real tin ear i think and it's not a
very
clever idea because his appearance at
the abbey seems to have been
how can we put it a bit stage managed by
prince andrew because there's been
briefings to the press that uh the rest
of the royal family understood he would
be traveling in the car with the queen
from windsor where they both live these
days to the abbey which is fair enough
but that he would then pass her over to
the dean of westminster abbey at the
back of the church and let him walk her
up to the front whereas prince andrew
would then slip rather more discreetly
into his seat
instead
there are reports that he refused to let
go of the queen's hand the dean had to
just sort of stand there and the duke of
york then marched her up the front of
the aisle in front of all the cameras
and that the rest of the royal family
were a bit cross with yeah but it does
say that prince charles and prince
william were reported to be dismayed in
quotes by andrew's prominent role at his
father
we had reports about prince andrew being
embroiled in a very embarrassing court
case what a convenience
anita very quickly because we've run out
of time um run us through the mac
cartoon in the telegraph
yes
this is it's pretty it's pretty
straightforward um the the view of many
russian oligarchs will be they're not
concerned about anything other than the
fact that actually our energy bills are
so high they may end up wanting to feed
a country for that reason um so forget
the cost of your super yacht forget the
costs of maintaining your home its
energy bills are going to send them
running to the hills
susie good old matt he's hit the spot
again hasn't he
yeah if any we could all leave the
country on a 25 million pound yacht that
would be handy wouldn't it unfortunately
thank you both uh see you at the top of
the eleven thank you